Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you're
a smoker who's been trying to quit, then boy
do we have good news for you!
I mean, relatively.
Anyone who's participated in DARE, or read
a scientific article, or been alive on planet
earth for more than a second, knows that cigarettes
are bad for you.
On average, smokers die 14 years before non-smokers,
and half of the smokers who don't quit, are
eventually killed by their habit.
So clearly, they're terrible.
But, you may be wondering, what happens after
I DO quit?
Can the effects of smoking be reversed, and
how long would it take for that to happen?
Before we answer that, let's examine the 2
major ways that cigarettes affect your lungs.
The first thing they do, is destroy cilia,
which are tiny little hairs that live in the
mucus lining of your lungs.
When you inhale pathogens or dirt, they get
trapped in that mucus, and the cilia is what
pushes them back out.
When you smoke cigarettes, the poisons in
them paralyze and destroy those cilia, making
it harder for you to avoid infections.
BUT, within just a few days of quitting cigarettes,
those cilia will start to regenerate.
And they'll continue to get better - until
eventually, your lungs return to their original
functioning capacity.
So that part - you absolutely can reverse.
Studies have shown that people who quit smoking
- and stay that way - reduce their risk of
lung cancer to that of a person who has never
smoked, within 10-15 years.
However - there is caveat.
Cigarettes can permanently damage your lungs'
alveoli, which are the tiny little air sacs
that absorb oxygen into your bloodstream,
and release carbon dioxide.
People who have been smoking heavily, or for
a very long time, are at much greater risk
for developing chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease.
That includes chronic bronchitis, which is
a potentially reversible inflammation of the
airways, and emphysema - which destroys your
alveoli, making it difficult for your lungs
to absorb the oxygen they need.
Unlike cilia, alveoli cannot regrow themselves,
so emphysema is a permanent - and devastating
- disease.
Even so, the effects of quitting smoking - begin
the day you stop.
Within a month, you'll feel like you can breath
significantly better than before - and within
a year, your risk of having a heart attack
is reduced by 50%.
According to the American Cancer Society,
smokers who quit before age 35 prevent 90%
of the risk of health problems from smoking.
And a smoker who quits before age 50 halves
their risk of dying within the next 15 years.
Norman Edelman is the chief medical officer
of the American Lung Association, and he says
that a smoker's risk for developing smoking-related
diseases, is directly correlated to the total
number of cigarettes they've smoked in their
lifetime.
The metric they use, is called "pack years"
- and it's the average number of packs a person
smokes, per day - multiplied by the number
of years they've been smoking.
The greater your pack-years, the greater your
risk.
And according to Edelman, people who have
50 pack-years or more under their belt, even
if they quit - will never completely reduce
their risk of lung cancer back to that of
a non-smoker.
Of course, genetics also play a huge role
in how cigarettes affect you.
Up until a few months ago, my dad smoked 2
packs a day for 55 years - and never once
experienced any adverse breathings effects.
But on the flip side, there are people in
their 20s, who smoked for 2 years and died
of emphysema.
So it really is different for everybody.
Also, dad - I'm really proud of you for quitting.
Enough about me though, what do you guys think?
Are you a smoker who's been trying to quit?
Or are you not convinced that the effects
can be reversed?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below, and as always - thank you guys for
watching.